ومع هذه الخلافات السياسيه المتصاعده لا
يزال مصير تمديد اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه غير محسوم بشكل واضح وتحديدا
فتره تمديده فنقلا عن الامم المتحده فان
المشاورات غير الرسميه مستمره بين المنظمه
الدوليه والاطراف المعنيه بخصوص التمديد
بينما تقترح موسكو تمديد الاتفاقيه لمده
60 يوما فقط تقول كييف انها ستلتزم
بتمديدها للضعف بهذا الخصوص اكد نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه لكسندر جيروسكو عند
روسيا اقترحت بالفعل تمديد اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب لستين يوما في المقابل قال وزير
البنيه التحتيه الاوكراني
ان موافقه روسي على تمديد اتفاق الحبوب
لهذه المده تتعارض مع الوثيقه الاصليه
الموقعه مع تركيا والامم المتحده
يمكن تفسير موقف موسكو بخصوص تمديد
الاتفاقيه برغبتها في الضغط من اجل رفع
العقوبات المفروضه على صادراتها ولو جزئيا
المحت اليه في وقت سابق